Tatort Deutschland präsentiert den
dunklen Januar jeden Tag ein neuer
Kriminalfall ein tägliches Tatort
Deutschlands Spezial mein Name ist Sky
du Mont und ich wünsche euch eine
spannende krimi-zeit hallo zusammen und
willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von
Tatort Deutschland daily ich bin Toni
Heyer und werde euch zusammen mit Mirko
Kasimir heute in die Vergangenheit
zurückführen hey Mirko hallo Toni ganz
genau wir gehen ins Jahr 1958
[Musik]
in Deutschland verdrängt der Kalte Krieg
das Wirtschaftswunder aus den
Schlagzeilen im Land wird über die
atomare Aufrüstung diskutiert man ist
entsetzt als in Ungarn die Anführer des
Volksaufstandes hingerichtet werden im
November 58 wird die Berlin-Krise ihren
Anfang nehmen die in der Blockade der
geteilten Stadt mündet die Musikcharts
heißen damals noch Hitparade und darin
feiert Peter Kraus Erfolge mit wenn
Teenager träumen oder Chris Howland mit
Fräulein in der Mode dominieren noch
hemdblusenkleider einfache Röcke und
Blusen aber der Mini wirft seine
Schatten voraus die Textilien werden
knapper zu den erfolgreichsten Filmen
des Jahres gehört es geschah am
hellichten Tag ein Thriller über ein
Kindermord mit Heinz Rühmann und Gerd
Fröbe und im selben Jahr erschüttert ein
kidnapping-pfalz junge Bundesrepublik
Deutschland im Frühjahr 1958
verschwindet der siebenjährige Joachim
Löhne
ein Entführer fordert Lösegeld für das
Kind doch als die Polizei sich später im
Zuge der Fahndung an die Öffentlichkeit
wendet geht es nur noch darum den Täter
zu fassen denn der Junge ist längst tot
von dieser Fahndung gibt es einen
Mitschnitt der bis heute nichts von
seiner Dramatik verloren hat gewissenlos
und brutal wurde versucht den Vater des
ermordeten Jungen zu erpressen
seit dem Verschwinden des Kindes am 15
April arbeiten die Ermittlungsbehörde
unablässig mit allen verfügbaren Kräften
und dahint Anstellung der Anliegen
geringerer Bedeutung an der schwierigen
Aufklärung mit heißem Herzen
ich bitte Sie heute im Namen der
Staatsanwaltschaft und des
Polizeipräsidiums Stuttgart bei der
Ergreifung der Schuldigen mitzuhelfen
von den Telefonanrufe des Erpressers
wurden tonbandauflage gemacht
die sie nach Ausräumung begründeter
Bedenken nun ausschnittsweise im
Original hören
machen sie der Kriminalpolizei Stuttgart
oder jeder anderen Polizeidienststelle
oder dem Stichwort Mordfall Gönner bitte
Mitteilung wenn Sie glauben die Stimme
des Täters zu kennen boah da hört man
den ganzen verzweifelten Ernst der Lage
ich meine da spricht der Mensch von der
Staatsanwaltschaft mit krassen
schwäbischen Akzent und einem dicken
Schnupfen aber man kann immer noch hören
wie krass der Fall die Leute mitgenommen
hat Mirko bevor wir den Tonband
Mitschnitt des Täters hören öffne doch
für uns die Fallakte erstmal ganz am
Anfang na klar Toni dazu gehen wir zum
15 April wir sind am Löwenplatz in
Stuttgart
dieser 15 April ist ein Dienstag der
siebenjährige Joachim Göhner ist Spross
aus der Familie eines textilkaufmanns im
Stadtteil Degerloch und wohnt in der
Löwenstraße 96
die Eltern sind geschieden das kommt in
dieser Zeit noch nicht so häufig vor wie
heute um die Abläufe und das Kind
kümmert sich eine Haushälterin
an diesem Dienstag will Joachim seinen
Freund Martin besuchen die Haushälterin
erlaubt es wenn er um 12:45 Uhr wieder
zu Hause ist aber keine 300 Meter von
seinem Zuhause entfernt am Löwenplatz
wird Joachim Göhner von einem Mann auf
einem Fahrrad angesprochen zunächst
beobachten sie gemeinsam ein
Eichhörnchen dann schlägt der Mann vor
an einen Ort im Wald zu fahren an dem
man ganz viele Rehlein sehen könne dort
könne Achim die Tiere auch anfassen und
streicheln der Mann verspricht dass die
beiden bis zum Mittag zurück sein würden
mit dem Rad sah dass er kein Problem
Achim steigt auf den Gepäckträger und
fährt mit dem unbekannten Mann Richtung
heidenwald
der Löwenplatz liegt am südlichen Rand
der Stuttgarter Innenstadt bis zum
anvisierten Wald sind es mit dem Rad je
nach Tempo 20 bis 30 Minuten das
Kindermädchen muss feststellen dass
Joachim nicht wie vereinbart um 12 Uhr
zum Mittag da ist auch um zwei keine
Spur von ihm am Nachmittag ruft die
Familie schließlich die Polizei ich kann
mir gut vorstellen dass man da schon
ahnt dass was Schlimmes passiert sein
könnte aber das noch nicht so richtig an
sich heranlassen möchte ich meine ein
Siebenjähriger der Tiere liebt der kann
ja mal die Zeit vergessen und das
Mittagessen vertrödeln ja das hofft man
zumindest aber Toni manchmal trifft das
Schlimme dass man ahnt eben auch ein
Achim bleibt verschwunden am Abend geht
der Vater Rene zur Polizei und gibt eine
Vermisstenanzeige auf die Beamten
beginnen sofort mit der Suche befragen
Nachbarn und fahrenden nach der
geschiedenen Ehefrau erst am Donnerstag
um Mitternacht klingelt dann das Telefon
bei den göhners sie haben die Nummer 7
32 30
ein leicht nuschelnder Mann ist dran
seine Stimme ist eher ein bisschen höher
als tief er fordert 15000 Mark für die
Freilassung des Jungen und für jeden Tag
Verzögerung weitere 5000 Mark
Achims Vater soll nach
stuttgart-weihingen kommen dort lägen an
einer bestimmten Stelle weiterer
Anweisungen aber es hat geregnet die
Schrift auf dem Bogen Papier ist nicht
mehr zu lesen das Ultimatum verstreicht
die Abläufe hat der pensionierte
Kommissar Michael kühner
zusammengetragen und 2016 bei einem
historischen Vortrag präsentiert das
wissen wir aus einem guten Bericht in
der Stuttgarter Zeitung aus den Akten
wissen wir das Rene Gönner noch ein
zweites Mal zu einer Geldübergabe
losgeschickt wird die auch wieder nicht
klappt übrigens bekommt der Vater das
Geld nicht so schnell zusammen die Stadt
Stuttgart startet ihn entsprechend mit
Bargeld aus die Polizei ist in dieser
Hektik schnell überfordert in einem
Artikel im Spiegel vom Mai 1958 heißt es
was die Polizei vermutet hatte
bestätigte sich beim zweiten Anruf des
Unbekannten er sprach von einer
öffentlichen sprechzelle aus es bestand
also die Chance Sprecher beim nächsten
Mal zu fassen wenn alle öffentlichen
fernsprechzellen überwacht werden würden
doch der mordkommissionsleiter frei
konnte sich nicht entschließen einige
hundert fernsprechzellen in Stuttgart
von je einem Zivilbeamten beobachten zu
lassen die geringe Zahl der Stuttgarter
Kriminalbeamten hätte allerdings nicht
für solch ein Unternehmen ausgereicht
doch wäre es angesichts der Tatsache
dass ein Leben auf dem Spielstand
zweifellos möglich gewesen aus anderen
Städten oder Bundesländern Verstärkung
heranzuschaffen die Polizei weiß also
nicht nur von der geforderten
Geldübergabe sie schneidet sogar alles
auf Tonband mit und das obwohl der
Entführer ausdrücklich davor gewarnt hat
die Polizei einzuschalten für den
kleinen Joachim ändert das sowieso
nichts er hat von Anfang an keine Chance
Mirko geh mit uns wieder ins
fallprotokoll am 22 April 7 Tage nach
dem Verschwinden von Joachim Göhner
macht ein Arbeiter in einem tannengehölz
im halbenwald einen grausigen Fund
ein totes Kind an Händen und Füßen
gefesselt er sieht anhand von Spuren im
Hals des Opfers was Gerichtsmediziner
später offiziell feststellen das Opfer
wurde erwürgt der genaue Todeszeitpunkt
ist übrigens bis heute umstritten weil
die Obduktion hier dem späteren
Geständnis widerspricht auf jeden Fall
steht die Polizei von diesem Zeitpunkt
an noch stärker unter Druck und biegt
erstmal falsch ab genau Toni die
Ermittler erhalten den Hinweis einer
Frau die ihren Ex an Schwert der Mann
heißt Krone Eis mit Nachnamen und ist
nach Angaben seiner Verflossenen kurz
nach dem Geschehnissen rund um Joachim
Löhner verschwunden sie hätte ihn für
dringend tatverdächtig
Frau das muss ja eine richtig tolle
Beziehung gewesen sein zeigte ihren
Typen an weil sie ihm einen Mord zutraut
am 25 April veröffentlichen die
Zeitungen das Foto des gesuchten mit
einem Fahndungsaufruf
kroneis wird schnell gefunden und hat
einen wasserdichtes Alibi und ist sicher
noch froh als vorher dass die Ehe vorbei
ist
tja wahrscheinlich aber die Polizei muss
wieder bei Null anfangen und gibt alles
so durchkämmen Hundertschaften den
fraglichen Wald nach Spuren ohne Erfolg
und Toni kann euch jetzt zeigen wozu
sich die Ermittler schließlich
durchringen
Kurt frei der damalige Inspektionsleiter
der Kriminalpolizei beschließt mit den
Tonbändern der aufgezeichneten
Telefonate an die Öffentlichkeit zu
gehen es ist durchaus nicht klar wie die
Erfolgsaussichten sind denn wie ihr
gleich hören werdet ist die
Aufnahmequalität äußerst bescheiden Ton
ab bevor sie das Band jetzt hören geben
wir Ihnen eine gewichtige Hinweise der
Fachleute der Anrufer spricht keine
ausgesprochene Mundart sondern eine
Umgangssprache die sich bis jetzt nicht
eindeutig lokalisieren lässt darum
werden sie aufgerufen sich beim Hören
Gedanken zu machen wo seine Sprache
beheimatet ist sie werden gebeten
besonders auch darauf zu achten ob ihnen
jemand bekannt ist der das Wort so wie
mit der besonderen Betonung spricht die
sie gleich hören werden und der
vielleicht als Eigenheit wenn Klappe
statt weltpappe sagt
wie lange wird das anders und wie lange
wird das andere
[Musik]
und haben sie was bekannt gegeben
verstehen
kennen Sie diese Stimme bitte überlegen
Sie genau
kennen Sie einen Mann der so spricht
hören sie gut zu
ja
eigentlich ganz genau angefangen
also es ist auf der einen Ebene
vielleicht unfreiwillig komisch was der
Mann am Telefon da sagt aber die
Menschen an den Radius in Deutschland
gruseln sich zu Recht hier spricht ein
skrupelloser Kindermörder es gehen 3000
Hinweise ein gleich mehrere der
Anruferinnen und Anrufer sind sich
sicher das muss der 40-Jährige Gärtner
Emil Tillmann aus Viersen im Rheinland
sein
Beamte fahren in die Jahnstraße 49 in
Viersen wo Tillmann zur Untermiete wohnt
und nehmen ihn fest der Mann ist nur
einen Meter 55 groß seine kriminalakte
aber schon lang der Gärtner ist wegen
diverser Diebstähle Polizei bekannt er
ist seit dem Jahr 1956 geschieden und
Vater eines Sohnes zu dem er keinen
Kontakt mehr hatte bei der Durchsuchung
der Wohnung finden sich reichlich
Beweismittel unter anderem eine
Gesichtsmaske Schnüre die zu denen
passen mit denen der siebenjährige
erdrosselt wurde so wie Überreste der
Botschaften der an die Familie Gönner
geschrieben hat aber klein die Stille
machen einen ja nicht mal eben zu Mörder
wie wurde der kleine Mann zum
Schwerverbrecher und da darf ich mal
einschieben
wenn Männer in so ein Fahrwasser geraten
dann doch wohl meist aus Habgier oder
Begehren und ratet mal beim kleinen Emil
war es beides wie die Ermittler
rausfinden bei einer Faschingsparty
hatte Tillmann eines Tages eine
48-jährige verheiratete Frau in
Stuttgart Degerloch kennengelernt und
sich offenbar Herz über Kopf wenn sie
verliebt die Frau erwidert die Gefühle
besteht aber auch finanzielle Sicherheit
vor einer Scheidung müsse klar sein dass
der nächste Mann auch flüssig sei
grundsätzlich verständlich man will ja
nicht gleich knapp bei Kasse sein wenn
man sein ganzes Leben total umkrempelt
wir wissen aus den Akten das Tillmann
nichts auf der hohen Kante hatte aber er
hat in den illustrierten kürzlich von
kidnapping-fällen in Italien gelesen und
sich von dieser Art der Erpressung
scheinbar inspirieren lassen
am 11 mai 1958 bricht Emil Tillmann sein
Schweigen und legt ein lückenloses
Geständnis ab er berichtet laut
Stuttgarter Zeitung wie er sich im
tannengehölz Handschuhe angezogen und in
arglosen jungen erwürgt hat noch am
entführungstag zur Mittagszeit
vier Tage später bestätigt die Polizei
auf einer Pressekonferenz die Festnahme
Tillmanns viele Reporter und Fotografen
sind dabei als der mutmaßliche Täter auf
dem Weg von der Polizeiwache zum
Gefängnis nach draußen geführt wird die
Ermittlungsakten werden am 22 Mai 1958
geschlossen aber noch bevor die
Staatsanwaltschaft den Fall übernimmt
und einen Prozess anschieben kann bringt
sich Tillmann um
am 23 mai nimmt er sich in seiner Zelle
am Stuttgarter Charlottenplatz einen
Gürtel und er hängt sich am
Fenstergitter er hinterlässt nur wenige
Zeilen ich habe jetzt alles gesagt und
hoffe sie werden damit zurechtkommen
das ist so ein krasser Fall und ich weiß
auf den ersten Blick gar nicht so
richtig warum die Tonbandaufnahme war
auf jeden Fall sehr eindringlich da ist
diese Banalität des Bösen in dieser
hellen Stimme und dieser Singsang der
Typ klingt absolut harmlos und
umgänglich und dabei ist das Kind längst
tot war das ging mir auch so ist aber
auch wieder mal so ein klischeeartiger
Fall wie aus dem Buch das harmlose Kind
beobachtete den Eichhörnchen und der
böse Mann schnackt es einfach mit
das ist wovor später alle Mütter in
Deutschland uns Kinder gewarnt haben geh
ja nicht mit Fremden mit auch wenn die
was Nettes versprechen oh ja das kenne
ich zu gut ich finde ja aber auch der
ganze Fall wirkt so als sein wir
Deutschen damals noch naiva gewesen
unschuldiger irgendwie tja liegt
vielleicht daran dass es noch nicht so
viele Medien gab über die solche Fälle
in die Massen transportiert wurden das
seit der Spiegel mal gut aufgeschrieben
dieser Fall Gönner war wirklich der
erste große kidnapping-fall in der
jungen BRD und dann dient der unter
anderem als Vorlage für einen TV-Krimi
aus der legendären Serie Stahlnetz von
1964 das war definitiv noch lange vor
meiner Zeit
das war unser Fall für heute wir haben
ihn nacherzählt mit Hilfe sehr guter
Artikel aus der Stuttgarter Zeitung und
dem Spiegel in den Show Notes findet ihr
außerdem den Link zur historischen
Tonbandaufnahme mit der Stimme des
Entführers Emil Tilmann aus dem
Landesarchiv Baden-Württemberg wir
danken euch fürs zuhören und hoffentlich
seid ihr weiter dabei bei Tatort
Deutschland montags bis freitags immer
ein neuer Fall Redaktion Stefan
Netzeband
Postproduktion durch die Studios